The last thing we're going to touch upon is just some slides that show off the
different setups you're able to achieve with the Chaos vehicle system depending
on your project needs. So the system is flexible enough that it allows you to
set up vehicles with any number of wheels. Just make sure that your
physics asset is set up correctly to account for each wheel and add as
many wheel blueprints as you need to the vehicle blueprint. And
if you want to set up a system where you're towing other vehicles, physics
constraints inside the vehicle blueprint are now much more reliable. The system
also allows for vehicles with less than four wheels. So when it comes to
vehicles like bikes or motorcycles with just two wheels, you'll find that fine
tuning is required to get some more desirable handling. And we've found that
experimenting with the central mass override and rotation damping under the
torque control settings really helps to stabilize the movement of the vehicle.
It also allows for different differential types and accurately simulates the
difference between front wheel and all-wheel drive vehicles. And if
mechanical accuracy of different differential types is important to your
project, you can now have confidence in your setup using Chaos vehicles.
Being built from the ground up, the Chaos vehicle system allows for
tackling various types of terrain. And a great feature when combined with
physical materials is to be able to determine the friction of a surface and
alter the handling of a vehicle depending on what surface they're driving on.
And lastly, there are a suite of debugging tools that show a visual
representation of what's happening to your car in real time. So you can drive
around your scene and see the forces acting upon the car. And this can help
you track down any bugs with the setup that you have and see the
changes you're making when you're tweaking various settings. It's also
important to note that the legacy debug mode still exists, so you can get
on-screen information for things like suspension and friction, as well as
plotting torque data all in real time. So overall, the debugging tool set has
been expanded.